hey just finishing up
see you again soon
how you doing
all right i guess
uh dale here he went to go hang out my
mama who by the way is at my house all
weekend so that's a no-go
okay what do you want to do later movies
putt-putt i was thinking maybe we could
go get a test
what kind of test
the pregnancy kind
we're closed but the sign said we're
closed
this can't be happening how sure are you
i'm not sure that's why i want to get
the test well you don't look pregnant
that's not how it works georgie
i know
i'm just freaking out right now let's
just go to the drugstore right
i feel like i'm going to throw up please
don't say that
i think i got it it takes 10 minutes for
the results you want me to go in with
you to watch me pee on a stick i'm being
supportive right now you could try the
same
i'm pregnant you sure not too heavy i
got it
[Music]
i guess it's time to do what people do
on their wedding night georgie we're
gonna be parents we don't do that
anymore oh right besides my water just
broke all over your bed that gum
stop having fun and help me take care of
these babies but i just got home from my
day job and i don't have 10 minutes to
my nut job that's 10 minutes you could
be helping now go change whichever this
one is
[Music]
georgie there's a band called guns and
roses on the phone
really yeah the guitar has hurt his hand
and they want you to fill in
[Music]
tell them i can't i'm a dad now
okay
this is a long 10 minutes
[Music]
well
i'm not
really we're good
oh thank god
what a relief i know
we better stop hugging her you're gonna
need another stick to pee on
i wonder who came up with blue raspberry
raspberries ain't blue it should be
blueberry you think
but blueberries ain't blue either
they're purple
the whole blue food situation in this
country needs some work
so what do you want to do
probably something with our clothes on
no kidding that was scary terrifying i
was afraid i was going to marry you
afraid
shaking in my boots and what exactly
would be so terrible about mayor and me
i didn't say terrible
you can be afraid of things that are
great
like what
uh
oh roller coasters
you're an idiot
roller coaster's a good answer
i didn't say sharks which is what i
thought of first you're making it worse
how is it worse i didn't say it
roller coasters is a good answer
[Music]
foreign